en la noche de este miércoles aquí en
tokio venezuela consiguió medalla de
plata en levantamiento de pesas fue
julio mayora en los 73 kilos quien se
quedó con esta presea de plata tras
levantar 346 kilos fue el chino quien se
quedó con la medalla de oro el gran
campeón campeón olímpico récord olímpico
récords mundiales y con 364 kilos
quienes sigue siendo noticia aquí en la
tokyo también es a simón varios tras
conocerse que no participará en la final
del concurso completo de gimnasia que
debe llevarse a cabo este jueves aquí en
la toqué un comunicado de la federación
estadounidense de gimnasia pues se
indicó que se van a centrar en la salud
mental de la deportista que se le van a
hacer evaluaciones diarias para saber si
podrá o no concursar en las finales en
las otras finales que le hacen falta y o
por último bueno pues creativo desde
aquí en natación la estadounidense que
por fin se colgó el oro esta vez fue en
1.500 son metros libre esa es su
especialidad la estadounidense ganó en
15 minutos 37 segundos y 3
cuatro centésimas por delante de su
compatriota el caso lehman y fue la
alemana sarah cover quien se quedó con
el bronce